what skill do I think everyone should
master to become more productive I would
say I'll cheat here I'm going to give
two but one is very concrete morning
meditation more 10 to 20 minutes you can
do this any number of ways I ended up
only adhering to the habit of meditation
after quitting many many times over the
years following a transcendental
meditation course and there are lot of
issues I have a transitional meditation
at least how its set up the costs
involved it's cheaper than it was then
and so on but it is very secular once
you get past the first day or so and you
have the social pressure or
accountability of working with an
instructor on daily basis for 4 days so
if you're going to meet with them and
they want to talk about the two sessions
that you did when you weren't together
you are going to feel like an ass if you
don't have something to report and this
is a very beneficial type of pressure
and that is what got me initially to
stick to the daily practice long enough
to make it a continual habit there are
other tools you could use for instance
like the app headspace which I have used
which many other people have used
millions at this point and they have a
10 in 10 I think it is which is 10
minutes a day for 10 days and you listen
to guided meditation which quite frankly
is easier than going directly to
something like TM which is mantra based
or any type of I think awareness
meditation without the so called
dis let's call it a distraction or tool
of a guided voice in recorded audio it's
actually a very very helpful training
set of training wheels in the very
beginning stages or you can continue to
use it I know someone for instance and
I'm going to butcher her last name
because I always do and I'm going to
embarrass myself here again
Maria poop OVA or Popova damn it Maria
I'm sorry it's performance anxiety with
your name I always do this who runs
brain pickings which started off as an
email to I think five of her friends and
ended up now it has seven million plus
readers per month she listens to the
same guided meditation
from Tara brach every morning and has
for years I think it's smiling
meditation or something along those
lines so it doesn't have to be a just in
the beginning thing so the meditation I
think if I look at for instance all the
world-class performers that I've
interviewed 80 plus percent have some
type of mindfulness or meditative
practice whether that is sitting down
palms and lap and meditating or running
for 10 20 30 miles and listening to the
same song these are all forms of
mindfulness training and it's a
prerequisite foundational skill I think
for operating at a very very high level
and there are certainly people who
haven't done that deliberately and have
achieved great success but I would
encourage everyone who's listening to
realize that being successful
objectively compared to other people and
feeling successful or two very different
things and ideally you want to have both
of those and it's not being egotistical
or egocentric I think it's being human
this type of mindfulness practice helps
with not just the achievement component
but the appreciation component and I
think that you are chasing after a
fool's errand if you're just going after
one or the other you don't have to it
can be both end the second foundational
skill and I'll try to keep this short is
getting better at asking questions
there are piss-poor questions there are
okay questions there are good questions
than there are great questions and I
find that levels of success in almost
any industry or area correlate to a
person asking great questions in some
cases they seem absurd in fact the
hallmarking way of great questions is
that sound completely ridiculous
so someone might ask like Peter Thiel
why can't you achieve your ten year
goals in the next six months there's a
thought exercise that's like--that's
that's a good question to answer for
yourself
and these types of questions come up
surprisingly often with with very very
impressive folks whether it's in
business
military entertainment or otherwise and
we get better at questions is by
studying interviews in part so I studied
Larry King
I studied Charlie Rose I studied Terry
Gross I studied that that go down the
list
I studied Tony Robbins who does in
person one-on-one interventions at his
events in front of ten thousand five
thousand people and he's just genius
with how he uses questions to like
pattern interrupt and grab someone's
attention and divert them in a more
productive productive direction now why
is that relevant relevant because
thinking is the process of asking
questions you're asking yourself
questions and then you're answering them
in your own head so if you get better at
asking other people questions you get
better at asking yourself questions
which means you are a you're improving
your thought performance and level of
thinking so those would be the
prerequisite skills thanks for watching
guys I hope you enjoyed it and if you
want to see more I have some fantastic
stuff coming including collaborations
just click here and you'll be the first
to see it